gervais munger républicain c'est une
grande fierté pour moi de pouvoir
participer à ce grand rendez vous d'une
importance capitale pour chacun d'entre
nous militants cadres acteurs de la vie
publique
c'est une transformation de nom mais
surtout de fond excite la politique
politicienne place au renouveau et au
débat françois hollande nous promettait
en 2012 de faire de la jeunesse sa
priorité
promesse tenue avec les rythmes
scolaires il a détruit l'école
républicaine et le tissu associatif
la réforme du collège a été passée au
forceps pour promouvoir le nivellement
par le bas et l'égalitarisme idéologues
de cette gauche bien pensante et enfin
il avait même envisagé la suppression
des bourses au mérite finalement diminué
de moitié ce jeudi et oui en social y à
quoi sert de récompenser ceux qui
travaillent quand on peut se permettre
un nivellement par le bras tout en
recrutant des milliers de professeurs
supplémentaires parce qu'en sociali on
préfère primes et l'égalitarisme plutôt
que le mérite
voilà le nouveau concept à l'école ne
travaille pas trop bien s'il te plaît
parce que ça risque de mettre mal à
l'aise qu'ils ne travaillent pas et oui
c'est ça la présidence normale et c'est
aussi cela que la jeunesse de france ne
veut plus nous sommes jeunes mais pas
irresponsable nous voulons retrouver
cette valeur fondamentale qui est le
résultat de notre engagement
la méritocratie nous devons faire des
jeunes de véritables acteurs politiques
non pas parce qu'ils sont jeunes mais
parce qu'ils le méritent
nicolas sarkozy a souhaité mettre en
place des débats des rencontres ancrer
la démocratie participative au coeur de
nos mouvements
alors allez-y partager participer cc
vous de tous les sujets et en avant pour
l'alternance
merci marine